près de 20 milliards de francs en
comptant les options cette nouvelle
commande fait de la compagnie allemande
le premier client d'airbus industrie
avant même eastern airlines lufthansa
choisi airbus pour remplacer certains de
ses boeing d'ici la fin de la décennie
le transporteur d'outre-rhin mise sur un
accroissement du trafic aérien dans les
années à venir
le gros porteur à 306 en est pour lui le
mieux placé sur les lignes proche
orientale et sur l'afrique comme l'a320
peut l'être pour les vols intra
européens
les airbus commandés bénéficieront de la
nouvelle motorisation proposée par
international aero engine
le consortium dont font partie rolls
royce et d'autres motoristes européens
cette nouvelle grosse commande de
lufthansa va permettre notamment à
toulouse de garnir le plan de charge des
ateliers de l'aérospatiale en outre ce
très gros client d'airbus qui milite
depuis longtemps en faveur d'un gros
porteurs long courriers européen
le thé à 11 pourra peut-être pesé d'un
poids plus lourd dans les programmes du
consortium un aussi gros clients se
lassent écoutent avec attention